bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france
une fois les troupes américaines
définitivement partie est ce que
l'aghanistan va inévitablement retomber
entre les mains des talibans selon vous
en tout cas c'est ce qui semble se
dessiner à moyenne échéance
effectivement il ya la situation est
mauvaise alors les talibans ont annoncé
qu'ils contrôlaient 85% du territoire
d'ores et déjà bon il faut se méfier des
chiffres parce que il ya une logique
auto enfin on va dire de prophétie
auto-réalisatrice 1 de la part des
talibans une une logique de propagande
très efficace d'ailleurs qui est
alimenté à la fois par des vidéos de
reddition de soldats de l'armée
nationale afghane de effectivement de
prise de contrôle des des points de
passage frontaliers avec les divers pays
limitrophes de l'afghanistan donc il ya
une pression a compté stablement très
forte inde et aliments qui qui suscite
des interrogations qui était attendu par
le retrait américain qui sera achevé fin
août
tel que l'a établi le président joe
biden donc la question et quinn après
effectivement alors achraf rani de près
le président du bo d'afghanistan a dit
que c'était des étapes les plus
difficiles effectivement pour son
gouvernement que le pays était néanmoins
susceptibles d'être contrôlés ça suscite
évidemment des interrogations pour le
moins et ça explique certaines
déclarations comme celles de l'oeil
aussi le chef du pentagone
face à cette pression des taliban quel
intérêt aujourd'hui pour eux de
poursuivre les négociations de négocier
un accord avec le gouvernement afghan
contrairement aux années 80 90
lorsqu'ils ont pris le pouvoir en 96 il
ya les talibans ont profité d'un certain
nombre de choses
ils ont acquis des des réflexes
différents en terme de communication
notamment ils ont fait beaucoup de
progrès d'ailleurs il ya une fatwa qui
vient d'être qui vient d'être relayé par
numéro deux des talibans le 24 juin 2000
tiens qui enjoint justement les talibans
les chefs militaires locaux de respecter
les civils à ne pas agir cruellement
d'essayer de deux justement de respecter
les biens des localités occupées et
c'est donc il ya incontestablement eu un
souci de crédibilité en termes de
présentation et notamment une en quête
de respectabilité internationale parce
que c'est ça qui se joue pour les
taliban et on voit d'ailleurs avec les
contacts qui sont entre anneaux avec les
chinois par rapport aux inquiétudes de
pékin justement pour leurs
ressortissants en disant mon nom mais
vous pouvez rester
on est donc c'est aussi une manière pour
les talibans de se présenter comme
potentiellement un gouvernement
quasiment prêt prêt à entrer en action
et face à hull face aux insurgés quelle
est la marge de manoeuvre du président
ashraf ghani pour reprendre son pays
le problème du gouvernement c'est qu'il
est il est coupé des on va dire des
zones rurales avaient d'ailleurs si la
stratégie d'asphyxié menée par les
talibans qui ressemblent toutes choses
égales par ailleurs à celle qui avait
été menée en 75 par les khmers à les
khmers rouges autour de ces deux
domaines c'est l'idée d' effectivement
d'asphyxier les villes pour qu'elle
tombe comme un fruit mûr avec l'idée de
éventuellement de prendre le contrôle de
kaboul sans véritable combat l'on n'en
est pas là parce qu'effectivement la
sociologie afghane a changé depuis 2001
la population s'est urbanisée elle a eu
accès un niveau d'éducation qui elle
n'avait jamais connu donc et puis il ya
le tropisme ethno confessionnelles qui
va ressurgir on voit d'ailleurs dans les
zones qui sont affectées par les combats
notamment la zone frontalière avec le
liant houleux des chefs de guerre
commence a manifesté des velléités de
résistance aux régionales comme les
semelles ram et là on va retrouver
effectivement des logiques milicienne
qui sont en train de sauver l'homme en
place d'ailleurs avec l'aval tacite du
gouvernement
quels sont les risques aujourd'hui pour
la région l'asie centrale d'une victoire
des talibans sur les forces afghanes
ce qui est certain c'est que les
talibans ne veulent pas être perçu comme
une menace par rapport aux pays
limitrophes et c'est pour ça que je
parlais de
de politique de communication au terme
de respectabilité internationale
d'ailleurs dans les négociations enfin
il ya une délégation qui était à moscou
et ils ont signalé aux russes qu'il
n'était pas question que l'été que
l'afghanistan redevienne un sanctuaire
pour des groupes jihadistes et que
notamment les talibans se faisait fort
de réduire la menace représentée par
l'état islamique du khorassan donc la
branche afghane de l'état islamique pour
montrer que finalement c'est eux qui
serait le garant d'une certaine forme de
sécurité du pays
donc là il ya effectivement une façade
de respectabilité qui construite qui est
très élaboré ce qui n'empêche pas que
sur le fond il est peu vraisemblable que
les talibans aient réellement changé une
délégation de talibans étaient reçus
hier déjà à moscou vous le rappeliez à
l'instant quel rôle peut jouer la russie
aujourd'hui dans ce conflit la russie
finalement comme les etats-unis le
l'objectif de des grandes puissances
c'est de faire que l'aghanistan ne
redevienne pas comme je le disais
précédemment un sanctuaire pour des
groupes jihadistes internationaux et de
ce point de vue là les talibans se
présentent comme des des islamistes
nationalistes en fait et c'est ça qui
joue là-dessus justement pour éviter
d'être de se voir à l'excès par une
image négative de proximité potentiel
avec al qaïda
même si les liens demeurent une certaine
manière on tire pas un trait comme ça
sur les liens qui sont de plusieurs
décennies mais en tout cas il ya
effectivement en termes de communication
une stratégie très élaborés finalement
des talibans qu'on a tendance à
sous-estimer très élaborée qui leur
permet d'avancer leurs pions y compris
par rapport à la population interne
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse david
larigot les roses rédacteur en chef de
la revue aurions stratégique